بان يحل العيد في اقليم كردستان العراق
حتى نرى المواطنه هنا مرتديا ازاي الكردي
الفلكلوري والمستوحي من الطبيعه الجبليه
والتلال ويعتبر الزي الكردي زي المناسبات
السعيده لكثره الوانه وتطريزاته وقماشه
الفاخر ما يميزهم عن باقي سكان العراق
ونحن نلبسه في كل المناسبات ونظهر به امام
الناس مميزين عن عشائرنا وقومياتنا والزي
الكردي مناسب لكل مكان ايضا
حزام من القماش يلتف حول خسر الرجال على
سترته وسروال وهناك من يرتدي الشماغ معه
وتختلف اشكاله والوان الشماغ من منطقه
لاخرى ومن عشيره لاخرى ويمكن ان يرمز كل
لون لعشيره كرديه لوحدها بين ان اختلاف
الالوان والتصاميم لا يغير من اصل وتصميم
هذا الزيت الالوان يعني كل واحد حسب ذوقك
يعني اكون لون اسود يلبسها
بارزاني يسمونه ايه يعني كل نوعيه وكل
واحد حسب طبعه هو شنو يحب من اللون
كله مدينه ولها زي معين اربيل لها زي خاص
ودهوك وايضا السليمانيه وكركوك ومناطق
هورمان ايضا لهذه معين
كبير على لبس الزي الكردي لجميع فئات
المجتمع هنا في اقليم كردستان العراق في
المناسبات والاعياد سيما عيد الاضحى
المبارك ما يعتبرونه زيهم القوم الفلكلور
الذي يميزهم عن سائر بلاد العالم فكل عام
والجميع بخير احمد الحمداني العربيه اربيل
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات